in sri lanka where in less than 24 hours
some 16.2 million
eligible voters will have a chance to
elect a new parliament
the vote which was delayed twice due to
the coronavirus pandemic
is seen as a test for sri lanka's
constitutional democracy
if the party of president gotabia
rajapaksa
wins a two-thirds majority in the new
parliament it would allow it
to bring changes to the constitution
changes that would give greater powers
to his office
and the frontrunner in the polls is the
president's own brother
campaigning in times of covet 19 was
kept to a minimum in sri lanka
but that did not dampen the excitement
of mahinda rajapaksa's supporters
rajapaksa the current prime minister is
the favorite
in the vote he's also the brother of the
president
whose work he highly praised
we don't have to explain what would have
happened if president rajapaksa
had not let the battle against the covet
pandemic
mahinda rajapaksa was appointed prime
minister only days after his younger
brother gutabaya
became president last november the
rajapaksas have long been one of the
country's most powerful families
mahinda rajapaksa was already once
president
and many sri lankans praise him because
he ended the long civil war
but there were also accusations of
authoritarianism nepotism and corruption
then came last year's easter sunday
bombings
in which more than 260 people were
killed in islamist attacks
the attacks made many sri lankans want
to return to the rajapaksa family's
sinali's nationalist
and buddhist agenda half a year after
the attacks
gotabaya rajapaksa was elected president
now he and his brother are planning a
major constitutional reform
if as expected they come out ahead in
the vote
critics say the rajapaksas want to
tighten their grip on
power by getting rid of independent
bodies that curb the power of the
president
but the opposition has not given up
[Music]
we will definitely form a government
with a heart
that understands the wishes of the
common man
and finds solutions for the problems
faced by the people
[Music]
analysts have little doubt that the
rajapaksas will win
the question is whether they will get
the big majority they need
to implement their desired reforms
[Applause]
joining me now from melbourne is amantha
pereira he's a researcher at australia's
cq university amanda thank you so much
for joining us
now the ruling party wants to win
a two-thirds majority to make changes to
the constitution
what are these changes and why are they
so important
well the changes have not been made
clear i mean we haven't had an
announcement as to detailing
what these changes are the speculation
is that
some of the changes are aimed at
probably undoing the amendments that
were brought about
in with the 19th amendment in 2015
and the likelihood of uh
the uh the two the 19th amendment
reimposed term limits for the presidency
so there could be a limiting a lifting
of those term limits also there are
uh the amendment also introduced
commissions and the appointment of
members to those commissions
where the presidential power
over them was decreased so the
likelihood that these commissions
or the appointment to these commissions
uh where the president's
hold on those commissions might be
reduced
will also be taken out and i think why
they have become important according to
the ruling parties
that they will give a more
stable hold on power for the executive
presidency
to push ahead with policies
as well as development and other work
and also
there is a lot of emphasis on security
and
the feeling at least among the ruling
party is that
you need a strong presidency to make
sure
that the security in the country is not
jeopardized
but but this security it comes at what
cost i mean just let's look at the past
few months
under president gotabaya rajapaksa i
mean he has created several task forces
for example
that are mainly comprised of sinali's
military and
police officials i mean is there a
danger that sri lanka is slowly sliding
into
ethnic majoritarian rule
well it actually depends with from
which side you're looking at this now
with the easter
tax there was a demand within the
country and especially
within the majority singular community
for
a far more stronger security
leadership and president rajapaksa's
victory
was based on that and he hasn't done
anything
that he did not pledge to do when he
campaigned for the presidency but on the
other hand
what we are seeing is also a regression
of uh the
more wider freedoms that
the country gained uh with the 2015
election
where you saw the right to information
act
being introduced press freedom
increasing
and at least a semblance of
investigations
being taken looking into uh
crimes and other violations that took
place during the war
so in that way yes there is this sense
that there is a de facto militarization
of the public sphere
in in sri lanka but whether that
is not the popular choice i think the
jew is still out on that
what exactly is at stake here for sri
lanka in these elections
well i think what really is at stake is
a decision
whether the country votes for uh
as you said a more security oriented
or a more military oriented uh public
administration
or whether the country looks at uh
continuing
what uh was there in the last five years
where there was uh more similar freedoms
but also chaos in terms of the president
and the prime minister
uh not getting along so i think that's
the choice uh that's confronting the
people
right now we'll leave it there for the
time being but thanks so much for
joining us amanda pereira researcher
at australia cq university
you